the World Health Organization is
changing the name of monkey pox to mpox
due to concerns that the original could
be considered racist which I didn't even
really think was an issue but now I'm
just wondering what's the n in n95
[Applause]
after this year's election a
record-setting 12 States will have
female governors
while while the other 38 States will
have dinner ready on time
foreign
[Applause]
or as Fox News will report it
undocumented Africans won wild in
streets of New York
the Postal Service announced a new stamp
honoring the late Supreme Court Justice
Ruth Bader Ginsburg there's also a stamp
honoring Clarence Thomas that says flip
me over and start licking
foreign
[Applause]
China has led to a Slowdown in iPhone
production wow so I guess the new
variant does affect children
a zoo in Atlanta will allow visitors to
carry firearms so you want to try
laughing at me again monkeys
what happened to you man
a white student at the University of
Kentucky was arrested after she was
caught on video using a racial slur and
assaulting two black students she has
been charged with one count of
impersonating a police officer
President Biden signed a measure that
would force Railway workers to accept a
deal that averts a strike but does not
include paid sick leave why do you
expect Biden to care about sick leave
when he shows up to work every day with
full-blown CTE
a 10 year old boy in Florida faces
misdemeanor battery charges after he
allegedly touched a teacher's breast
because under Florida law students are
required to wait for their teacher to
make the first move
a new study finds that during the
pandemic students math scores drop by
almost 10 percent wow so more than half
an apple Factory in China is expected to
cut production of iPhones by 6 million
in response to ongoing worker protests
the workers main demand is more play
time
foreign
[Applause]
since Elon Musk took over Twitter use of
the n-word on the site has reportedly
jumped 500 percent it's the biggest
increase in the use of the n-word since
the last time I stubbed my toe
NASA has released an image of the Sun in
which it appears to be smiling so if the
sun can smile would it kill you ladies
to try it
foreign
that its Pilots intentionally flew a
flight path that created a giant penis
pointed at Russia
even worse they then fired missiles
this week marks the 40th anniversary of
the classic Michael Jackson albums
throne
and say what you will about Michael
Jackson but he definitely had a huge
effect on a lot of people's childhoods
I don't know what you guys like yeah
President Biden said that he plans to
run again in 2024 but won't make a final
decision until early next year because
it's like his doctor told them I
wouldn't plan too far ahead
a police officer at New York State
a police officer in New York state is
being called the baby Whisperer after he
helped deliver his fifth baby in nine
years only five babies in nine years
said Nick Cannon
okay there you are okay
Thursday was National No broad day which
I celebrated by not supporting women
it's a broad joke
this week President Biden pardoned
thousands of convicted marijuana users
and it feels like maybe he celebrated
with him a little because yesterday
Biden gave a speech at a car factory and
opened with this
let me start off with two words
made in America
[Applause]
some parents in Oregon are having large
groups of their children ride their
bikes to school at the same time in a
formation they're calling a bike bus and
pedophiles are calling a buffet
[Music]
China has launched the third China has
launched the third and final module for
its permanent space station now all they
have to do is launch some children to
assemble it
border officials have discovered four
hundred thousand dollars worth of meth
hidden inside pumpkins they could tell
the pumpkins were full of meth because
they only had like three teeth left
Wednesday was National Coffee with a cop
day and something tells me cops like
their coffee with a couple of shots in
it
Planned Parenthood Planned Parenthood
says it will soon open its first mobile
abortion clinic in the country which
will make it easier to provide care to
patients anywhere in the country that
Herschel Walker has visited
police in Queens were searching for a
suspect who hijacked the bus and then
immediately crashed it into a utility
pole okay so we know it's a woman
no that's great Pebbles who was the
world's oldest living dog has died at
the age of 22. but it's okay his owners
knew this was coming if they didn't keep
him off my yard
[Laughter]
I'll say that a report of a homeless man
sleeping on a bench turned out to be a
statue which was a huge relief because
they shot it 15 times
Southwest Airlines has changed their
policy for emotional support animals and
will now only allow cats and dogs on
board while over its Spirit everyone's
given a snake
a man in Virginia is being called the
greatest Uber driver ever after he and
his teenage passenger got stuck in a
snowstorm and he got a hotel room so she
would be safe coincidentally the worst
Uber driver ever also brought his
teenage passenger to a hotel room
scientists have trained the Goldfish to
drive a car they believe it's the first
step to eventually training women